mais d'abord les négociations entre
socialistes et insoumis une première
historique que nous raconte flora
sauvage et gaspard flamande cap sur les
législatives alors que la france
insoumise affiche son ambition de placer
jean luc mélenchon à matignon délégation
socialiste a fait le déplacement ce
mercredi au siège de l est finie
l'objectif construire un programme
commun avec les insoumis arrivé
largement en tête de la gauche au
premier tour de la présidentielle
il ya clairement une volonté de afficher
une rupture avec le bilan qu'a été celui
de françois hollande on nous a dit
qu'ils avaient pas de difficulté à
s'engager sur l'abrogation de la loi
elle comme rick avait pas de difficulté
à s'engager sur la 6ème république avait
pas de difficulté à s'engager sur le
blocage des prix qui sont pour nous des
marqueurs et des points programmatiques
extrêmement important de telle sorte que
honnêtement on n'avait pas l'impression
de discuter avec le même parti
socialiste que il ya deux ou trois ans
de ça après deux heures et demi de
tractations les discussions semblent sur
la bonne voie mais blanche et noire nous
avons eu une discussion constructive qui
nous a permis d'avancer sur un certain
nombre de points permettant de voir et
de considérer qu'il n'y avait pas entre
nous deux points de blocage
insurmontable pourtant cet accord ne
fait pas l'unanimité au sein du parti
socialiste
la stratégie de l'effacement c'est une
tragi quiconque
qui aboutit à l'effacement électorale et
que là se ranger derrière jean-luc
mélenchon c'est d'effacement finale
envisagèrent un accord avec les insoumis
serait un tournant majeur pour le parti
socialiste de leur côté les instruments
ont entamé des discussions bilatérales
avec chacune des forces de gauche pour
espérer une victoire législative les 12
et 19 juin
législatives 2022 la gauche grand place
et voient le titre de notre débat avec
catherine tricot directrice des éditions
de la revue regards bonsoir catherine
vous mettez jean luc mélenchon à la une
de votre revue dans sa dernière édition
victor de là je m'en sois d'être
responsable des études à la fondation
pour l'innovation politique albert et
nous devons soit l acte en chef du
service politique du figaro on a
également avec nous en duplex rémi
lefebvre qui est politologue professeur
de sciences politiques à l'université de
lille bienvenue vous publiez fois qu'il
est désespéré de la gauche c'est aux
éditions textuel et j'accueille
également mathieu croissandeau
éditorialiste politique bonsoir soir
mathieu la gauche grand emplacement vous
appliquez le titre 1 c'était là une
dinde un autre numéro de regards avant
la présidentielle évidemment les 22% de
jean luc mélenchon ça change
sérieusement la donne oui on peut dire
que c'est une surprise étonnante pour la
gauche ans on s'attendait à avoir les
eaux les plus basses et finalement ça
reste quand même assez basse bon après
2017 c'est le plus mauvais résultat
totalisé de la gauche mais dans un cadre
de tripartition de l'espace politique ce
qui fait que finalement avoir 32 % cela
et non mais 22 mais j'ajoute le reste de
la gauche c'est à dire que total des
gauches monde approche à 32% corps donc
quand on est dans un espace nautique est
divisé en trois finalement 32% vous avez
un tiers des voix donc vous pouvez jouer
et c'est ce que je veux faire jean luc
mélenchon et ça explique les tractations
et négociations en cours victor de l'âge
c'est surtout le ps qui pourrait être
remplacé si on reprend l'expression ce
parti joue sa survie financière sa
survie politique
je reprends l'expression l'effacement le
risque d'effacement c'est certain que le
ps joue énormément à travers ces
législatives si on prend le le bloc de
gauche
sur les suffrages exprimés jean luc
mélenchon au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle ça représente 75 76 %
donc on voit que c'est que jean luc
mélenchon suite bien sûr à ce premier
tour est en position de force al'inverse
on voit que le parti socialiste a fait
un score très bas si d'ailleurs on mais
on va dire dans le même sac la gauche de
gouvernement c'est à dire le parti
socialiste et europe écologie les verts
on est autour de six 6 5 % ce qui
représente un score similaire à benoît
moindre en 2010 est donc on voit
effectivement que le le ps est en
position vraiment de faiblesses et doit
désormais composer avec elfi pour
véritablement trouvé et retrouver
peut-être sa place dans cet espace
politique est totalement bouleversé ce
qu'on sentait bien dans ce reportage
albert et nous le ps est en train de
lâcher du lest sur sur beaucoup de
thématiques ont quand même le ps avait
le choix entre la soumission et la
disparition il a choisi la soumission il
aura la disparition on voit pas comment
le ps pourra s'en sortir jusque là ils
en sont à discuter de quelques
circonscriptions l'essai ou sortant du
psg et où à quelques socialistes et qui
vont
avoir une se compter sur les doigts
d'une main les députés socialistes et on
se fond dans une masse et le ps tel
qu'on l'a connu mon français est unique
de la gauche forcé les présidents des
partis gouvernement va disparaître et je
ne suis pas sûr qu'il pourra renaître de
ses cendres alors c'est vrai que au sein
du parti socialiste il ya deux tendances
ceux qui comme levier fort accès de
cette soumission et vont aller chercher
quelques circonscriptions vous et c'est
qu'elles constituent un groupe il ya au
moins dix députés ce qui est pas su et
puis on a d'autres qui essaye de
construire avec très très difficile je
sais que demain
françois hollande qui va doit prendre la
parole donc est-ce qu'il va essayer de
reconstruire quelque chose dans cette
gauche socialiste social démocrates
réticents il faudrait presque acté la
mort de ce parti c'est à changer de nom
inventer autre chose et c'est ce qu'on
va vous y êtes en fait les faits les
faits on
déjà acté les bien sûr mais que c'est
difficile pour ceux qui sont à
l'intérieur de dire oh ben voilà c'est
fini on ne s'appellera plus parti
socialiste je pense que la stratégie la
stratégie elle est mortifère pour le
parti socialiste se ranger derrière
jean-luc mélenchon ça veut dire la fin
du parti socialiste tout simplement donc
et s'ils continuent dans cette voie
c'est continuer avec rien et ne même
plus avoir de d'existence propre
discours programmatique et seront cédés
logique puisque il se met derrière alors
bien sûr will the hills accompagne les
accompagnent la soumission d'un jean luc
mélenchon disons qu'on n'est pas tout à
fait d'accord on aura notre voix mais au
sein d'un groupe qui sera sans doute
fort elle est fille et ne passeront pour
rien du tout
reparler des socialistes rémi le faire
j'ai j'ai ouvert mes titres avec des
expressions presque désuète à union de
la gauche programme commun gauche
plurielle et ça nous ramène à l'histoire
du parti socialiste est ce que cette
mort du ps donc on est en train d' acte
et quand est-ce qu'elle démarre pour
vous il démarre en demie 2 avec la
non-qualification de lionel jospin vous
vous dater sa de quelle époque
moi je serais plus réservé ou pas sûr du
tout on assiste à la mort du ps je pense
que le ps n'a que des mauvaises
solutions il choisit l'option qui lui
permet de préserver une armature de
député on ne sait pas encore grand chose
de la négociation mais rien n'interdit
le ps dans six mois parce que je ne
crois pas du tout qu'il y aura une
cohabitation et que j'aurai avec jean
luc mélenchon sera premier ministre rien
n'interdit le ps dans six mois une fois
qu'il aura eu vingt ou vingt-cinq
députés peut-être de s'émanciper
concrètement je pense que les partis
politiques là à gauche sont très
pragmatiques
jean luc mélenchon cherche à avoir le
maximum de députés il sait qu'il a
besoin des autres partis il a besoin
d'apparaître le rassembleur pour pouvoir
profiter de la dynamique de l'élection
présentielle le ps lui joue sa survie
bon des partis politiques ça meurt très
difficilement moi je ne crois pas à la
mort du ps peut-être un land
décomposition mais le ps aujourd'hui il
n'a il ne peut pas faire autre chose il
peut pas faire autre chose si jamais il
décide de ne pas s'unir avec jean luc
mélenchon il n'aura pratiquement aucun
député et donc il a pour le coup pour le
coup il va s'effacer donc là pour
l'instant je pense que c'est une
position pragmatique
bon c'est une manière aussi tranchées
des divergences je pense que ça aide
olivier faur par exemple à se
débarrasser de lèse de droit de droite
ou hollandaise de deux du ps parce que
c'est un problème il ya un énorme
conflit donc il ya une clarification qui
est en jeu voilà après le ps la question
pour répondre à votre question la
question c'est de savoir si encore un
espace au centre gauche pour le bourg
dans l'espace politique ça c'est une
grande question que je pense que je
terminerais là dessus le calcul que font
ensemble de dirigeants socialistes c'est
que cet espace va à nouveau s'ouvrir
parce que le deuxième mandat de macron
va être très à droite parce que macron
ne sera pas candidat à sa réélection et
donc ils pensent 4
alors on a un petit souci technique ça
arrivait à tournai ont
entendu la fin mais on a bien compris
votre votre propos
rémi le faire une 4ème tricot on va
rentrer dans le détail de 2 des
négociations là on est sur le ps on
parle d'europe écologie les verts un peu
plus tard mais moi je me mets à la place
des électeurs qui sont de gauche depuis
longtemps et qui qui se sont attaché
soit au programme de fabien roussel soit
celui d'anne hidalgo mais s'ils
n'étaient pas très nombreux et qu'ils la
voient les tractations et où on
abandonne une partie du programme tout
ça presque d'un claquement de doigts moi
je suis pas tout à fait certaine qu'on
abandonne tant que ça c'est à dire qu'en
fait ce qu'ils aient l'impression qu'on
a là un reportage avec phil réaction des
socialistes est belle si en même temps
si vous voyez les éléments de que bêtes
en avant et les fit finalement sont des
éléments qui sont assez consensuel à
gauche c'est à dire que y'a quelques
points de difficulté par exemple l'âge
de la retraite avec le parti socialiste
le nucléaire avec le parti communiste
mais ils vont trouver des solutions et
je pense pas qu'ils vont imposer aux
forceps ce grand large l'europe on y
reviendra tout à l'heure de l'europe
c'est une authentique et sur l'europe on
va faire un focus sur l'europe dans ce
débat ça c'est promis la personnalité de
jean-luc mélenchon était là un frein le
frein principal à une
à une union de ces partis de gauche
regardez ses affiches de campagne pour
les législatives et
on dirait la présidentielle c'est pas
compliqué c'est mais c'est bien matignon
que le fondateur de
la france insoumise veut s'offrir
mathieu avec ces négociations jean luc
mélenchon il tient un peu sa revanche
sur ses anciens camarades du ps on peut
dire ça oui oui ils se connaissent par
coeur il faut le dire entre jean luc
mélenchon les socialistes ça jamais
était de l'histoire ancienne le leader
des insoumis a beau avoir claqué la
porte du ps il ya 14 ans il n'a jamais
cessé de se construire en contre il
voulait réussir à l'extérieur ce qui
n'avait jamais réussi à faire de
l'intérieur lui l'éternel minoritaires
devenir majoritaire dans son propre camp
effacée du paysage ses anciens camarades
qui avaient rebaptisé les solférinien un
peu comme s'ils étaient une secte ou
comme c'étaient des reptiliens passer
devant le ps aux élections incarner la
gauche à lui tout seul bref tout ça
c'est aujourd'hui chose faite
les voilà qui viennent lui manger dans
la main qui demandait un accord pour
sauver leur siège leurs finances leur
logo ceux là même qui par la voix de
l'accès de leur candidate anne hidalgo
lui reprocher à lui jean luc mélenchon
il ya encore deux semaines d'être un
agent double a dit mi-août il un
démagogue ou de vendre français des
promesses absolument intenable alors
quelle revanche quand même il faut le
dire françois hollande disait adobe de
cette campagne que ce n'était pas
l'union qui faisait la force mais que la
force qu'ils aient l'union mais
aujourd'hui la force c'est lui comme
vient de le reconnaître
lionel jospin ancien de ses camarades
passé comme lui parle oci dans le
parisien hier qu'il
a salué son échec glorieux la
présidentielle et son talent et donc
voilà les socialistes réduit au rang de
vassaux de supplétifs prêt à l'aider à
obtenir une autre revanche parce qu'en
fait c'est pas tellement la revanche les
socialistes qui n'intéresse jean luc
mélenchon 71 c'est essayer d'avoir une
revanche après cette troisième défaite à
la magistrature suprême en devenant
premier ministre oui c'était pour y
parler est ce crédible trouvaille de
l'entre-deux tours comme a surpris plus
d'un parce que vous souvenez au soir du
premier tour jean luc mélenchon c'est un
discours puis finit en dix ans est mieux
à ces jeunes à ses jeunes partisans dix
jours plus tard changement de cap élisez
moi premier ministre lance t-il puis on
peut le voir c'est désormais imprimé sur
comme un slogan unique sur le tract pour
les législatives alors est-ce que patron
des insoumis s'est trompé d aider
d'élections on rappelle que il fait fi
de notre constitution d'une certaine
manière au rapport de ceux qui aiment le
président qui est choisi et qui nomme le
premier ministre mais lui rêve de se
voir imposer
l'hôtel matignon par le vote des
français un peu comme lionel jospin
encore lui chef de l'opposition l'avait
été en 1997 après le naufrage de
dissolution vous souvenez pas par
jacques chirac mais le verdict sans
arriver ça très peu de chances d'arriver
d'abord parce que depuis l'inversion du
calendrier et le quinquennat il ya
toujours une forme des faits de souche
présidentielle après aux législatives ça
serait inédit que ça que ça ce ne soit
pas le cas et on a vu les choses
inédites en politique donc faut jamais
dire jamais mais il ya quand même
traditionnellement un effet mécanique
parce que les français n'aiment pas pour
certains se déjuger pour d'autres a jugé
ajoutez du cao cao ou de la difficulté
la difficulté ensuite parce que même en
mettant son son visage sur sur les
affiches
elles se sont pas 577 jean luc mélenchon
qui vont se présenter dans les
circonscriptions mais bien des candidats
plus ou moins bien implanté plus ou
moins bien légitime plus ou moins bien
douées souvenez vous quand même qu'en
2017 on avait déjà fait un joli score la
présidentielle près de 20% là il a fait
un peu plus de quasiment 22 mais ça lui
avait valu que 17 députés parce que là
pour le coup il n'y a pas d'effet
mécanique les chances de pouvoir se
maintenir au second tour elles sont
minces on sait on a déjà rappelé la
règle y signant 12 5% des inscrits donc
avec une abstention qui pourrait frôler
les 50 % serré pour faire 25 % d'où la
nécessité de rassembler son camp pour ne
pas que les voix se disperse au premier
ça explique soudain qu'il se montre lui
jean-luc mélenchon plus magnanime avec
ses anciens camarades dont il ne voulait
pourtant plus entendre parler ça
explique qu'il accepte qu'ils gardent
peut-être leur identité ce de leur logo
sous une bannière commune lui qui
pestaient contre les soupes au logo ça
explique peut-être qu'ils soient
d'accord pour des accords d'appareil lui
qui disait que c'était de la vieille
cuisine de la vieille tambouille tout
est bon pour mélenchon reste à savoir si
les socialistes les électeurs
socialistes comme les caciques
socialistes accepteront à leur tour de
dû servir de marchepied victoire de la
sueur sur la partie peut-être tout
personnalité ou égaux il faut de lego
pour faire de la politique personne n'en
doute mais quand même ça est-ce que ça
peut être un frein à la personnalité
d'une chanson dans ces négociations ou
pas parce que finalement dans les négos
c'est pas lui face aux autres candidats
des différents partis je pense que la
fiche que vous avez montré montre montre
un petit peu tous et julien bayou
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui le secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts
qui par les tensions justement avec l
efi en pointant la volonté hégémonique
de jean luc mélenchon dans cette danse
dans ce début de campagne
rappelons qu'il ya quelques jours de
cela jean luc mélenchon et donc son
groupe et les filles ont proposé une
lettre de répartition de candidats
europe ecologie les verts et également
au parti communiste et dans cette liste
jean luc mélenchon proposé que
427 candidature soit elle est fille et
que seulement alors on va on va le
raconter ça parce que c'était l'objet
notamment une conférence de presse
d'europe écologie les verts cet après
midi non on a quand un calme et pardon
de vous interrompre et il va nous le
nous le raconter vous faisait référence
en revanche à cette réaction de julien
bayou c'était dans une interview à
libération ce matin on laisse qui dit en
détail
jean luc mélenchon veut-il être premier
ministre nous disons chiche gagnons
ensemble mais l'alliance ne peut pas se
faire avec une volonté hégémonique c'est
quand même assez révélateur de deux là
effectivement des des craintes on va
dire exprimé par une partie des des
écologistes et alors je vous propose de
feu de d'aller plus loin parce que quand
on dit europe ecologie les verts
aujourd'hui mais il faut aller chercher
les différents sons de cloche donc y en
a deux qui sont bien différents il ya
celui du candidat yannick jadot et puis
celui de celle qui était arrivé en
deuxième position aux primaires
écologistes
regardez ce qu'ils disent quand il
s'agit de se ranger ou porte derrière le
leader et les films vous entendez la
france insoumise et 10 on est ouvert on
tend la main mais derrière nous derrière
jean luc mélenchon peut pas ça marchera
pas mais ça marchera pas si je vous
disais lui chef la non non
je reconnais tout à fait le leadership
de jean luc mélenchon là-dessus il n'y a
pas de sujet il est arrivé premier aux
potes la fin du premier tour de la
présidentielle on va pas refaire le
match il est premier c'est à lui de
mener cette coalition bon yannick jadot
c'est sandrine rousseau pas d'accord
c'est pas exactement une surprise mais
quand même on va rentrer dans le détail
quentin calmez vous pouvez nous
rejoindre deux de ces
négociations on avait dit que si on a vu
que ça s'était plutôt correctement
passée en tout cas ces messages
officiels entre le parti socialiste et
elle est fille aujourd'hui mais en
revanche depuis 24 heures c'est
compliqué avec les verts exactement les
négociations était secrète depuis le 21
avril
et puis bien depuis lundi elles sont au
point mort on peut le dire la france
insoumise a été très dur dans un
communiqué publié aujourd'hui le parti
demande de la clarté à europe ecologie
les verts et explique que depuis 48
heures donc depuis lundi plusieurs
dirigeants sont revenus sur les
engagements programmatique qui avait été
acté entre les formations politiques
le communiqué vous le voyez qui cite la
retraite à 60 ans le blocage des prix du
carburant ou encore la désobéissance
envers les traités européens
il y aurait donc trois points de
désaccord programmatique au passage le
parti de jean luc mélenchon envoie un
petit taquet aux écologistes avec cette
phrase certains dirigeants de élevé sans
l'utiliser nos discussions pour régler
leurs désaccords internes nous ne
souhaitons pas être instrumentalisée
dans ce qui semble être la préparation
du prochain congrès de élevé explique le
communiqué donc ce matin le négociateur
de la france insoumise a repris cette
critique écoutez manuel bompard
maintenant si vous m'interrogez sur
europe écologie les verts c'est vrai
qu'on a un certain nombre de difficultés
ces derniers jours dans les discussions
on va pas le cacher parce que justement
on a l'impression d'assister parfois
davantage à une sorte de congrès
d'europe écologie les verts plutôt que
la préparation d'une majorité pour
gouverner ce pays et donc on commençait
à l'évoquer en urgence les verts ont
convoqué une conférence de presse cet
après midi exactement elle rendez-vous
15 heures fixes et que les journalistes
l'idée était de faire preuve d'une forme
de transparence dans les négociations
aussi peut-être un thomas de
redistribuer les cartes dans cette
partie de poker menteur on peut le dire
alors il refuse toute idée
locale sur le programme que ce soit sur
l' europe 1 ce qui reste selon eux eu
effectivement un point de vigilance mais
qui n'est pas un problème en soi sur le
carburant ils disent qu'il faut que ce
soit temporaire le blocage des prix ou
encore sur la retraite ils sont d'accord
pour l'âge lille le martèlent ils sont
favorables et bien à une coalition avec
une plate forme programmatique et des
éléments en commun écouter le secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts
tout à l'heure nous sommes pour un
accord voilà je le redis
nous voulons un accord il est possible
il ya rien sur le projet qui est
parfaitement insurmontable comme eva sas
vous l'a dit et le mandat comme nous a
donné le conseil fédéral comme vous l'a
expliqué alain est très clair nous
voulons un accord le plus ambitieux
possible pour envoyer des bataillons de
députés écologistes et de gauche à
l'assemblée nationale dès donc il ya
bien un accord sur sur le fond en
revanche il ya bien des problèmes il ya
bien effectivement des points de tension
notamment et bien on en a noté deux la
bannière tout d'abord l'accord doit se
faire sans hégémonie disent les
écologistes il ne peut pas se faire dans
la structure de l'union populaire les
écologistes proposent anciens front
populaire écologiste et sociale donc un
nouveau nom donné à cette coalition
autre point d'achoppement les
circonscriptions gagnables c'est tout le
nerf de la guerre bien sûr les
discussions tourneraient autour d'une
dizaine seulement deux circonscriptions
gagnables pour les verts c'est
inacceptable pour la direction du parti
qui a joué vraiment cartes sur table 1
qui a montré les schémas des
négociations aux journalistes qu'il est
qui leur a dit être prêt à cesser
d'évoquer avec le nombre de
circonscriptions les ont affiché sur les
murs vraiment en disant voilà c'est
c'est la transparence de ce qui ce qui
coince dans les négociations alors
qu'est ce qui se joue donc voile c'est
ya un hiatus comme sale mais les
arguments des deux pas des deux parties
or on a posé la question à julien bayou
ou non se demande s'il ya une une
sincérité de la volonté d'aller chercher
cette majorité alternative c'est ça
l'enjeu veulent t'ils se donner les
moyens de gagner
jean luc mélenchon premier ministre est
ce que c'est
vrai qu'il le souhaite ou non parce que
si il le souhaite et nous souhaitons une
majorité alternative
alors dans ce cas là il faut pouvoir
additionner les électorats pour ça que
nous parlons de coalition il faut
entendre cette envie de rassemblement
qui monte évidemment comme vous
certainement nous nous entendons très
fort mais qui n'est pas une demande de
disparition ou d'un visibilisation voilà
on est dans l'impasse on est au point
mort et les écologistes fixe à samedi la
samedi pourrait bien sortir de cette
impasse la date limite de négociation
merci quand alors je vous redonne la
parole victoire de là j'étais une grande
parenthèse dans notre démonstration mais
on la nourrit d'une certaine façon parce
que il ya un argument qui qui me semble
juste c'est que c'est effectivement par
une alliance que qu' il ya une capacité
à remporter le plus de sièges pour la
gauche en général ou les gauches ça
c'est évident oui d'autant plus que ça a
été rappelé tout à l'heure il ya 577
circonscriptions en france pour être
majoritaire il faut en gagner 289 290
donc c'est vrai qu'on voit mal jean luc
mélenchon
avoir de 190 candidats sortir victorieux
dans autant de cirque autant de
circonscriptions après derrière cela
aussi il faut bien avoir à l'esprit
qu'il y a un enjeu financier pour les
parties on pourra peut-être en parler un
petit peu plus tard mais n'oublions pas
que des partis comme le élevé mais aussi
le parti socialiste sont au plus mal
financièrement et commençait derrière
chaque élection législative c'est parti
là peuvent se renforcer financièrement
puisqu'ils peuvent toucher des dotations
publiques à travers plusieurs mécanismes
donc il en va aussi de la survie
financière de ces parties là oui on peut
on peut détailler ça c'est vraiment les
finances des partis politiques adverses
et nous qui les lys latif c'est la
source de financement principale c'est
la source de financement principale
chaque chaque député chaque candidat si
pour chaque parti qui a moins 50
candidats qui totalise -1% à 1 et voit
touche 1 euros 40 par par bulletin de
vote donc ça peut être ça peut être
conséquent ça dure cinq ans donc c'est
tous les ans ils la manne financière
continue donc il est stratégique de pour
beaucoup de parties d'être présent aux
législatives et avoir le plus de
candidats possibles et ce qui est le cas
pour le ps qui est le cas pour le pur
pour leur assemblée nationale ce qui est
le cas aussi pour reconquête eric
zemmour pour tous les partis donc mais
si je reviens sur sur le ps est là et
fait la gauche en tous les cas
moi je rappelle toujours phrase de karl
marx à l'idéologie dominante et énergie
la classe dominante quand vous avez un
jean luc mélenchon est un défi qui est
qui est ultra dominant hégémonique bas
il impose ses vues c'est à chacun
d'accepter ou pas mais
le ps et les verts
devront aller
oui c'est à vous de faire des
concessions et bien sûr alors mais après
l'intelligence l'intelligence jeu
reprend l'argument de julien bayou on a
vu sur le centenaire
l'intelligence de bénéfices et de lâcher
quand même aussi du less pour des sucres
et une coalition qui sera placée sur
l'adversaire faut pas oublier le vaincu
le dans les vaincus mélenchon sort
plutôt vainqueur mais il faut se
rappeler aussi qu'il n'a fait que 20 %
et est arrivée troisième ne s'est pas
qualifié au second tour donc pour
l'instant on a l'impression qu'il a
gagné l'élection qu'il qu'il est en voie
de premier league la fiche le montre
quasiment président de la république
enfin il reste toute la statue de 10
mètres et puis on avait le lider maximo
sait on voit bien qu'on va bien la
position de mélenchon qui est qui et qui
est de faire d'avoir une stratégie ultra
personnalisé et enfin c'est vraiment
gérer pas jusqu au culte de la
personnalité mais en tous les cas on
voit bien que l'élément principal ce qui
va le point du marketing avec mélenchon
mélenchon et quand les candidats seront
désignés on va regarder quelle est la
place des candidats très joli mélange si
vous aurez nous en tout petit
mais souvent comme ça comme c'était avec
le cas avec la manière en photo à côté
d'emmanuel macro et jean luc mélenchon
se souvient quand même ce qui a été
rappelé tout à leur camp en 2017 il
avait perdu enfin il avait eu très peu
d'élus donc là une faut absolument
qu'ils mobilisent son camp donc vous
croyez qu'il y aurait une coalition anti
oui je pense qu'il y aura une coalition
parce qu'il donne un objectif politique
qui l'arrangent lui c'est comme ça qui
va réussir à mobiliser son électorat qui
sans ça ne viendra pas parce qu'ils ont
le sentiment d'avoir perdu et que donc
l'affairé pliée qu'on passe à autre
chose donc s'il veut mobiliser son
électorat il faut qui leur donne un
objectif de conquête est par ailleurs
cet objectif là malgré tout il est à
thénia pour les autres quand alliance
avec mélenchon mélenchon a besoin de
dire qu'il fit l'union pour rassembler
son camp et pour créer une dynamique on
fait le parti socialiste et d écologie
s'ils peuvent pas y aller mais les
communistes doivent pas y aller seul
sait aujourd'hui que
bien sûr cet acte du vote utile et tous
les électeurs premier tour de mélenchon
ne sont pas mêlant choisissent pour
autant oui ou deux électeurs
traditionnels du ps ou des mêmes des
verts s'en sont réfugiés dans la
candidature mélenchon pour éviter
notamment la dce était très volatile
dans les dernières 24 48 ans mathieu il
aurait pu jouer moi je trouve que ces
négociations les écologistes comme les
socialistes sont propres un peu de
maturité dans les négociations parce que
ils y vont comme à canossa prêt prêt à
tout à tout lâcher pour pour s'allier
alors que leur seul pouvoir est un
pouvoir de nuisance dire que s'il
s'allier et communistes écologistes et
socialistes dans une espèce de petit
paul qui n'aurait pas beaucoup de
députés joue la corde même très très peu
mais il serait sûr de gêner les insoumis
et donc ils peuvent là ils peuvent
organiser leur pouvoir de nuisance ne
font pas autre chose afficher de façon
transparente des négociations en cours
personne fait sa personne oui mais bon
ça fait du bien parce qu'on nous dit
toujours ce sont des discussions
programmatiques salanon de fait on prend
les circonscriptions au coach des noms
on dit tiens là pour être en négociation
si vous savez que le type qui vont
négocier sort et affiche exactement le
contenu des négociations ben vous
négociez pas pareil la deuxième fois et
encore moins la troisième fois
étonnant c'est de voir que jean luc
mélenchon revient sur une partie de son
programme aussi un donc
là les changements institutionnels on
verra plus tard le blocage des prix ça
peut être là aussi affable il
accepte t il on n'en parle plus pendant
longtemps ça a été sous les communistes
qui ont été le fer de lance de 7 2 7 7
ans vit entre l'état mais rejoint à
parler et parler les filles des deux
d'empêcher par exemple eric zemmour de
se présenter parce que parce que
condamné pour injures racistes et et on
voit bien que
les filles investi tawaf qui est qui a
été condamné pour lé à peu près les
mêmes raisons et ça ça ne me dérange pas
prêt donc je reviens vers rémi lefebvre
j'espère que la liaison est meilleur que
tout à l'heure ce qui est aussi
intéressant rémi lefebvre là j'aurais
sur la question europe ecologie les
verts c'est que ces négociations c'est
aussi un révélateur d'une obligation je
ne sais pas de clarifications interne
quoi c'est ce sont aussi les dissensions
internes d'europe écologie verts qu'on
les connaissait se sont exprimés dans
notamment lors des primaires et quand
sandrine rousseau a été un peu mise de
côté de la campagne de yannick jadot
mais mais là ya peut-être un besoin de
clarification
oui je vais pas sur les négociations et
des crocs liste est qui puisse clarifier
c'est plutôt un élément de faiblesse
pour pour les écologistes
je retiens quand même delà de
l'intervention de julien bayou que les
les fines ne souhaite que donner 10 x 10
circonscriptions au vert là vraiment
c'est très très raide quoi dix
circonscriptions ça veut dire même pas
un groupe politique un groupe
parlementaire ce qui est l'objectif
évidemment des verts parce que je me
fais pas d'illusion je le répète jean
luc mélenchon ne sera pas premier
ministre et je pense que dans six mois
ces forces politiques vont re
fonctionner en groupes politiques
attention il ya un jeu de poker menteur
autour de cette cohabitation tout le
monde fait comme si cette hypothèse
était réaliste mais elle n'est pas
réaliste là l'objectif c'est d'avoir
chacun le maximum de députés évidemment
de créer une dynamique de rassemblement
vis-à-vis de l'opinion pour mobiliser
les électeurs et intéresser les
électeurs de gauche à un scrutin qui ne
va pas trop les mobiliser a priori et
voilà ensuite je pense que il est
probable que les divisions de la gauche
vont reprendre leurs droits la seule
chose c'est que si et les filles à 80
députés c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose que 17 députés aujourd'hui et donc
est évident que les rapports de force
aujourd'hui au sein du bloc de gauche
risque de d'être de plus en plus en
faveur de la france insoumise à l'issue
de ces élections législatives
catherine est ensuite monté au jeu mais
moi je voulais juste revenir sur la
clarification à l'inter des deux
organisations partis socialistes et même
peut-être parti communiste et
écologie enfin je veux dire ils sont mis
sur il y avait des tensions à
l'intérieur de leur organisation
est ce qu'on veut une écologie radicale
ou pas est-ce qu'on veut revenir sur le
bilan de françois hollande ou pas
malgré tout est-ce qu'on veut affirmer
l'autonomie du parti commises mais ça a
été tranchée d'une certaine manière le
parti socialiste et notamment sa
candidate anne hidalgo en voulant pas
absolument pas réouvrir la boîte du
bilan de françois hollande à elle a été
complètement
à empêcher véritablement de produire un
discours et donc je pense que ces
négociations et ne sont pas que des
négociations de places elles vont aussi
acté des équilibres à l'intérieur des
organisations en faveur probablement
d'une écologie plus radicale en faveur
d'ardana d'un examen critique
bien sûr y ait une différence majeure
enfin il y en a deux c'est que
d'habitude ces deux partis europe
ecologie les verts et le ps télé partie
où le débat interne était très nourris
très vif et portait lors de congrès part
d'émotion où les gens défendent et des
idées parfois des poses parfois des
hommes et des femmes mais en tout cas il
y avait une confrontation interne très
forte la vouloir résoudre tous ces
problématiques toutes ses divisions en
quinze jours ça
un au siège des insoumis sans en passer
par les militants c'est les partis qui
ont une tradition militante qui ont une
tradition de débat un congrès ça se
prépare voilà moi je trouve que c'est
assez effarant la deuxième chose c'est
que pour nouer un accord de coalition un
accord de majorité ça se fait rarement
quinze jours l'agent lui poser de
mélenchon est en position ultra
dominante mais souvenez vous vous situez
la gauche plurielle la gauche plurielle
c'est l'aboutissement d'une certaine
façon inespérée avant l'heure parce que
il ya eu la dissolution mais c'est
l'aboutissement d'un processus ait eu
quelque chose dans mon souvenir
s'appeler les assises de la
transformation sociale qui avait été
lancée après la défaite de lionel jospin
à la présidentielle en 95 ans qui a vu
en tout cas deux ans de grand raout de
gauche où on essayait plus ou moins
entre écologistes socialiste et
communiste veut se mettre d'accord sur
une sorte de revival du programme commun
ça ces deux étapes et le débat interne
et la négociation interne et la
négociation externes n'ont pas eu lieu
donc c'est quand même assez bien on
parle d'europe pour terminer et pour
évoquer les divergences et la capacité
éventuellement de ces familles de ces
gauche de se réconcilier sur la question
européenne mais avant il faut comprendre
les divergences et pour ça petit coup
d'oeil rapide dans le rétroviseur
c'était y'a pas si longtemps c'est la
campagne présidentielle quatre candidats
de gauche écouter
l'europe c'est l'espace qui va nous
permettre d'avancer sur la transition
écologique sur la lutte contre les
inégalités notamment et aussi sur la
question de notre souveraineté à tout ce
qu'ils voulaient du made in france vous
êtes obligés de fermer les frontières
sur certains produits très bien si vous
voulez le faire alors vous devez
répondre à une question comment vous
faites alors que c'est interdit par les
traités européens un père dit dont vous
sortir de ces traités il faut sortir des
traités en général je suis pas pour un
système de l'europe à la carte quand on
voit la nécessité absolue d'une
politique de défense quand on voit
l'europe qui vient de 2,2 de bannir qui
va bannir tout un un nombre de molécules
chimiques
qu'ils imposent à l'industrie de la
chimie de transformer pour protéger la
santé d'environnement y'a que l'europe
pour ça je souhaite que le futur
gouvernement et futur président de la
république est un mandat donné par les
français
pour aller re négocier des traités
européens et retrouver notre
souveraineté démocratique en matière
européenne pouvoir définir nos propres
choix économiques et ne plus dépendre la
kiss des directives européennes
alors victoire de lages qu' il ya une
ligne possible commune a trouvé sur
l'europe à sa part extrêmement difficile
parce qu'on sait que le parti socialiste
de par son histoire a quand même une
relation très personnelle singulière
avec l'union européenne on se souvient
bien sûr des relations notamment de
françois mitterrand avec le chancelier
allemand et al'inverse on sait que
notamment principalement jean luc
mélenchon a eu peu tendre vers
l'europhobie c'est à dire qu'il est
contre l'union européenne qu'ils
souhaitent se sortir des traités pour la
réforme est donc effectivement par
rapport à ce que disait monsieur bompard
en début d'émission on voit qu'il ya
certains points de convergence je pense
que celui sur sur la question européenne
sera bien difficile il ya aussi à cela
bien sûr les enjeux
de l'otan on sait aussi par rapport à
tout ce qui avait été dit en début de
campagne les relations entre la russie
et jean luc mélenchon donc on voit que
ça sera quand même difficile de se
mettre d'accord sur ces sujets là et
puis j'ajouterai comme comme on parle de
françois mitterrand qu'on pourrait
peut-être recommandé aux instances des
différents partis qui sont qui sont un
peu des certaines querelles qui sont
encore elle qui lie à un passage
magnifique dans un livre qu'il avait
publié en 77 me semble-t-il la rose au
poing ou il dit justement que à cette
époque les forces de gauche sont très
divisés et que à l'exception du parti
communiste les autres forces de gauche
n'existe pas c'est à dire que les
citoyens ne savais même pas les nominer
les noms des différents partis et donc
dans ce passage qui est tout à fait
remarquable il il incite véritablement
les forces de gauche à s'unir derrière
le parti communiste pour pouvoir exister
et refonder véritablement une gauche de
valeur hier le parti communiste social
le parti social
avec
qui à cette époque très puissant
catherine tricot la question nucléaire
comment on passe que vous pour vous
c'est le point de blocage majeur n'ont
pas forcément non non moi je crois pas
du tout la question oui non parce qu'il
ya ces thèmes non j'ai dit la question
nucléaire de seulement c'est le jour de
la toussaint questions européennes à bas
la moyenne je pense que la question
européenne est un problème avec les
partenaires m'ont socialistes et
écologistes mais notre problème c'est
que emmanuel mâcon pas rester président
donc je dirais il va devoir il va devoir
composer c'est bien de le rappeler de
temps en temps et voilà non mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que du coup moi ce
que je pense c'est que jean luc
mélenchon s'il ne veut pas annoncer une
crise institutionnelle majeure donc au
cas où il gagnerait soit la majorité
soit la majorité relative un sas on ne
parle jamais de ça parce qu'en effet il
gagnera probablement point la majorité
absolue mais la majorité relative compte
une cet éclatement en trois pôles ne
peut y avoir emmanuel macron peut ne pas
avoir la majorité absolue et qui aura la
majorité absolue le plus fort de la
majorité absolue c'est ça l'unité son
billet un peu plus ouverte à mon avis
que la question d'acheter absolue
pourtant que mélenchon mais pas son seul
point ce que je veux dire c'est si
jamais jean luc mélenchon arrive à
matignon le problème c'est qu'il arrive
à matignon avec un président qui lui ne
fait pas mystère de son attachement au
traité à l'europe etc et puis il y aura
l'europe donc je pense que tout ça ça va
être devant il va devoir montrer ses
capacités de d'invention de souplesse
albert et nous
on se pose la vraie question enfin on ne
fait pas semblant de de poser là sur la
table l'hypothèse
d'une alliance l'hypothèse d'une
victoire même relative mais est ce
qu'ils y croient eux-mêmes d'après à un
mélenchon premier ministre soit une voix
une majorité relative à la chambre de m
c'est une posture on va au combat en en
disant qu'on va gagner toujours c'est un
classique mais au fond d'eux-mêmes et
savent très bien que
l'équation est à multiples inconnues et
donc leurs pattes il ya peu de chances
que que jean luc mélenchon même allié
avec les verts et socialistes puissent
avoir la majorité absolue ou même
relative ou suffisamment relative pour
imposer à sa pose et parce qu'il
faudrait arriver numéro un et numéro 1
et puis compte et épique et avec qui
d'autre aurait des défections dans les
autres dans les autres groupes donc
ça me paraît très très compliqué mais je
reviens sur sur sur l'europe
quand jean luc mélenchon parle de
désobéissance européenne fin des traités
européens pour à la fin pour les
socialistes je pas comment ils peuvent
faire pour s'associer à s'associer avec
lui et les verts c'est une ligne
s'éteignent rouge à franchir c'est ce
sont deux parties qui sont profondément
européen et on est engagé dans la
construction des pnc
avec le faire une alliance et peut-être
avec le rassemblement national la nuance
sur cette question dans les airs c'est
presque des fermes qu'on entend aussi
dans la bouche des marines up ça va être
compliqué je pense que c'est pas évident
il ya une dernière question j'aurais
avoir abordé peut-être avec vous mathieu
parce que in fine ne faut pas
sous-estimer le pouvoir d'attraction des
manuels macron après une 2e victoire
présidentielle sur une partie de cette
gauche le ps on le voit avec rebsamen on
voit là on a déjà évoqué mais peut-être
aussi un peu chez europe ecologie les
verts tout dépend des des signes et des
symboles qui l'enverra après moi je
doute que
de mettre tout le respect qu'on doit à
françois rebsamen et sur son nom il
puisse entraîner une majorité
d'électeurs de gauche
déçus non alors il ya l'hypothèse
yannick jadot
je pense que l'ouverture le maquereau
niable
davantage du côté des écolos que du côté
de la gauche et de la droite qui l'a
déjà fait en 2010 est là il faut que
faut qu'ils innovent y avait eu barbara
pompili avec le succès qu'on sait
d'entendre dans le gouvernement jadot
dit que cette rumeur court pour le
discréditer c'est vrai c'est vrai mais
en tout cas ce n'est pas du tout sur la
même de ce côté là que kemal m macro
cherche après il ya surtout un effet
mécanique on en a parlé tout à l'heure
et puis pour les insoumis ils savent
qu'ils sont très minoritaires bataille
culturelle on va dire la gauche et
minorités en france les quand même cc
32% mais il reste 70 % et donc ils ont
très peu de chances à offre comme l'a
dit catherine une forme de débouchés
politiques imaginaire et c'est un slogan
fédérateur formidable de pouvoir dire à
tous les jeunes convoqués mais voilà
élisez moi premier ministre mais ça
reste une chimère reste à savoir ce
qu'ils feront de leurs nombreux députés
et si ça permettra de reconstruire une
gauche à peu près unis mais il est
permis d'en douter car tête pour cette
jeunesse un futur espoir déçu on a vu
comment elle avait réagi au soir enfin
dans les jours qui suivaient le enfin en
tout cas pour une partie de cette
jeunesse qui suivaient les résultats du
premier tour de cette présidentielle
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat rémi le faire j'appelle le titre
de votre livre faut-il désespérer la
gauche c'est aux éditions textuel et
puis on peut être on peut peut-être voir
aussi la une de la revue regards avec
justement jean luc mélenchon la gauche
s'est lui voilà c'est votre dernier
numéro merci encore à tous